franck gastambide et matthieu delormeau
c'est très simple je vais vous expliquer
l'histoire à prendre quelqu'un au
téléphone et je vais poser des questions
sur marseille il faudra donner 10 bonnes
réponses
le plus rapidement possible tant que
vous n'avez pas les 10 bonnes réponses
vous continuez à tous et attend alors tu
te rends là dedans et les élus moment
attendu valeur ce bâtard et d'y envoyer
aviez je veux pas le faire je vais
m'énerver vous avez vu chronique et on
peut voir là aussi on a deux mois mais
pour moi alors les chéris attention
c'est que des questions sur marseille on
va mettre le gros dos il faut faire 10
bonnes réponses on va dire en une minute
ouais d'accord est ce que les gens ont
vu qu'il ya des verts paris monde voit
les animaux d'accord syria ça on va
alors avoir ne me touche pas le faire
partout dans la voiture on a quelqu'un
en ligne thibaut soirée vous faire un
très bon ces données viennent y aura
plein de goodies de taxi il ya des
cadeaux louf
alors monsieur bonsoir moi ta beauté
bonsoir bonsoir comment tu t'appelles ça
ne frédéric fredericton faut qu'il
réponde à dire
réponse j'ai plus un temps d'une minute
d'accord attention
plus ça va plus ça va aller vite
attention à ce que vous êtes prêts les
gars
[Applaudissements]
quand plan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] c'est tout dit mais cette quête
sur l'autre à la caisse un navet c'est
bon train dérive c'est gagner parce
qu'ils ont fait